bonjour jean marc flipo merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin avec nous sur
rt france jean-marc chipeau vous êtes
avec nous on va on va se comment dire
vincent chauvet va nous rejoindre dans
quelques instants pardonnez moi donc on
va commencer avec vous jean marc flipo
sur cette question de l'abstention il y
a une mission d'information aujourd'hui
à l'assemblée sur les ressorts de cette
abstention et les mesures qui
permettraient de renforcer la
participation électorale quelle est
selon vous la principale raison de ce
désintérêt
boukella la raison principale de ce
désintérêt c'est que on a on a un
éloignement progressif de des électeurs
de la vie politique on a bien vu il ya
deux ans maintenant de cela sur les
ronds-points tous les français qui
manifestaient pour le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne c'est un message
qui est envoyé au gouvernement qui
justement fait la démonstration de cet
éloignement qui est ressenti par les
citoyens nous ça fait des années que
nous proposons effectivement que le
recours au référendum qui est dans
l'esprit de la constitution de la vème
république soit beaucoup plus fréquent
que ce qu'il est aujourd'hui et puis
nous avons aussi une proposition forte
depuis des années qui est la
reconnaissance du vote blanc c'est à
dire qu'à partir du moment où un scrutin
le vote blanc est majoritaire et bien à
ce moment là on doit valider le scrutin
et on doit interdire ou candidats qui se
sont présentés de se représenter voilà
ça c'est ce qui va permettre un
renouveau de la démocratie
c'est ce qui va permettre de rapprocher
le citoyen de du système du système
interdire aux candidats de se
représenter à partir de quoi à partir
d'un certain seuil
puis à partir du moment avec scout et à
partir du moment où le vote blanc arrive
or iter ça veut dire qu'il ya un désaveu
complet des candidats qui sont moi qui
sont présentés donc il faut
effectivement un seul qui soit
suffisamment haut pour pas que ça
devienne du grand n'importe quoi mais il
faut reconnaître d'une manière ou d'une
autre le vote blanc c'est une
revendication qui est qu'il constante à
chaque fois que vous faites des enquêtes
d'opinion dans le corps dans le
reportage que vous venez diffusée cet
été évoquée vous avez des gens qui nous
veulent qu'ils ne se reconnaissent pas
dans l'offre qui leur est proposé qui
vole qui veulent un changement de vie
politique voilà c'est un peu d'ailleurs
ce qui s'était exprimé en 2017 avec la
vague mac ronde a voulu le voir des gens
de nouvelles têtes alors à vue on a vu
des gens qui étaient faites complètement
déconnecté c'est un autre problème mais
au moins il faut qu'il y ait un brassage
de la vie publique et qu'on ne revoit
pas toujours les mêmes à leur permanence
devant les électeurs alors on va en
parler plus en détail on est en train de
se connecter avec vincent chauvet ce
chiffre que de 60 % quand même des
électeurs qui ne sont pas allés voter au
premier tour des régionales et secousse
est comparable avec la présidentielle où
les les taux d'abstention sont quand
même inférieur
on ne sait plus quoi penser on ne sait
plus quoi penser d'autant qu' on est
dans un climat qui est très spécial je
rappelle qu'il ya quand même selon
gérald darmanin ya neuf pour cent des
professions de foi qui n'ont pas été
distribués lors des dernières régionales
face et 1 c'est invraisemblable là aussi
tout ça parce qu'on a voulu privatiser
le système de distribution face et
comment voulez vous que les gens aillent
voter si déjà l'offre qui l'aurait qu'il
aurait fait ne leur parvient pas c'est
pas en arrivant au bureau de voix qui
vont se mettre à lire les professions de
foi donc il ya quand même les comme des
efforts à faire avant de tout bousculer
il ya des efforts à faire pour
rapprocher le citoyen de des élections
maintenant traditionnellement c'est vrai
que l'élection présidentielle c'est
l'élection mère dans notre pays j'espère
qu'il y aura une participation plus
importante et d'ailleurs c'est un
message que nous adressons régulièrement
électeurs si vous voulez que les choses
changent dans votre pays il faut que les
électeurs avaient voté ce que disait un
grand démocrate péter abraham lincoln
disait un bulletin de vote et plus est
plus puissant plus fort qu'un qu'une
balle de fusil voilà il faut se servir
de ce bulletin de vote il faut aller
voter si vous voulez que les choses sont
les abstentionnistes aujourd'hui peuvent
renverser la table c'est entre leurs
mains que se situe élection
présidentielle et c'est l'enjeu et tous
les partis essaye de faire revenir ces
abstentionnistes dans le jeu y
parviendront-ils selon vous est ce que
vous lisez ce que l'offre finalement des
candidats est trop vaste comme le disait
par exemple cette dame dans le micro
trottoir
on va vous savez l'actualité récente
montre que dans le monde on a plutôt un
problème de manque d'offre plutôt que de
pléthore d'offres les français sont
suffisamment matures pour pour faire
leur foi la foi seule le français est un
et est un citoyen qui est quand même
hautement politisée par rapport à ses
voisins non ça je suis pas inquiet sur
le fait que les français sachent faire
le discernement entre les autres l'homme
mais encore faut-il que lors que leur
parviennent et encore faut-il que
l'offre
leur soient expliquées un tant soit peu
on voit aujourd'hui dans les médias une
hystérisation de la vie politique enfin
on arnad faut voir que le gros le gros
de l'antenne est monopolisé par
quelqu'un qui n'est pas candidat c'est
ça s'est encore jamais justement on à
vincent chauvet qui est avec nous le
maire modem qui étend au téléphone avec
nous pour ce débat vous parler
évidemment de d'eric zemmour est ce que
ce serait lui qui pourrait faire bouger
les les abstentionnistes selon vous
vincent chauvet alors effectivement le
temps d'antenne est monopolisé par deux
candidats qui ne sont pas candidats
parce que le président de la république
n'est pas également officiellement
candidat mais par rapport à ce que
disent et votre interlocuteur je
voudrais simplement dire que depuis 2014
le vote blanc est pris en compte il
n'est plus décomptés avec les nuls on a
pu blancs et nuls mais on a blancs d'un
côté nul de l'autre après on peut
toujours
dire ce qu'on veut mais quand il faut
élire quelqu'un à part quand le nom de
famille de la personne et monsieur blanc
on n'élit pas une personne
creuse ou un bulletin blanc il faut
quand même pouvoir choisir un candidat
la reconnaissance du vote blanc elle a
été portée notamment par la famille du
centre est là elle est aujourd'hui
abouti ce qu'il faut pour mobiliser les
électeurs c'est effectivement une offre
politique large et c'est pour ça que au
modem on plaide est depuis longtemps
pour la proportionnelle qui permet que
tous les votes comptent aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que quand vous votez pour des
législatives par exemple et bien 50% ou
49% de dd vote ne vont pas compter
d'autres élections qui sont à la
proportionnelle notamment les élections
municipales sont un peu plus investi
parce qu'on est aussi dans la proximité
on a regardé ce qui s'est passé aux
régionales et puis aussi juste avant
municipal où on a connu des taux
d'abstention très fort et on se rend
compte que finalement c'est assez
comparable
toutes choses égales par ailleurs à ce
qu'il se passait avant était le co vide
qui a fait un certain nombre de gens ne
se sont pas bousculés skill et qui est
important de voir c'est ces deux qui ne
votent pas aujourd'hui il y a après donc
ils ne sont qu une consultation à
l'assemblée sur le site de l'assemblée
nationale vous pensez que ça me servira
à mieux déterminer qui sont ces
abstentionnistes
alors oui régulièrement on est sondée
par l'assemblée nationale le sénat ou
tel ou tel article d'opinion on sait
très bien qu'ils ne votent pas et des
gens qui ne votent pas parce qu'il ne
souhaite pas voter donc à moins de
rendre le vote obligatoire est une
politique et il existe en france pour
les sénatoriales pour les grands
électeurs on ne pourra obliger les gens
qui ne veulent pas de vacciner à
vacciner les gens qui ne veulent pas
voter à voter en revanche on a beaucoup
de gens qui sont peu ou qui sont mal
inscrits notamment les jeunes qui sont
souvent inscrits chez leurs parents et
parfois qui sont à la fac à plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres ils se sont
laissés là où on a les plus
abstentionniste les jeunes ah oui très
clairement et ça se voit très facilement
les listes d'émargement son public vous
pouvez aller dans votre préfecture alors
jusqu'à 1 1 an je crois après la fin du
scrutin mais allez voir qui a voté qui
n'a pas voté et établir des statistiques
précisé il a l'insee les arts de manière
tout à fait certaine les jeunes les
jeunes sont très majoritairement
abstentionnistes ou et pourtant pour
voit à l'écran un sondage nick pour
cette présidentielle il serait 87 % à
vouloir aller voter alors c'est bien de
vouloir aller voter ensuite c'est bien
de pouvoir voter et là on voit que
certains sont mal inscrits nous au modem
on a fait une proposition justement sur
ces jeunes c'est de dire finalement on
se rend compte qu'un jeune qui vote à 18
ans il a beaucoup plus de chances d'être
toujours électeurs à 98 ou 88 ans ou 60
18 ans que quelqu'un qui n'a pas
commencé à voter quand on commence à
voter on continue à voter et c'est pour
ça qu'on pense que notamment ouvrir
peut-être aux élections locales le vote
aux électeurs de 16 ans qui se passe
dans de plus en plus de pays d'europe ça
permet dès le départ de bien inspirés de
finaliser cet électorat qui si dès le
départ il est lâché ou ne vote pas parce
que c'est trop compliqué parce que ils
sont loin ils sont inscrits à un endroit
et le divin autre endroit et bien là on
fabrique des abstentionnistes vincent
chauvet on va donner la parole à
jean-marc thibault on va écouter d'abord
gérald darmanin depuis ce que loïc
daniel mach a promis de mettre en place
ce vote à distance pour simplifier les
choses c'était sa promesse voyez ce
qu'on dit le ministre de l'intérieur qui
y travaillent mais qu'il n'y est pas
forcément favorable
regardez
le président de la république dans son
programme a dit qu'il était favorable au
vote à distance donc je travaille sous
son autorité à mettre en place le vote à
distance personnellement je suis très
attaché au fait que c'est un caractère
absolument solitaire le vote il ne faut
pas que votre mari que votre curé que
vos enfants que votre communauté voit ce
que vous votez et vous oblige à voter
quelque chose jean marc flipo que pensez
vous de la mise en place de ce vote à
distance
écoutez je vous surprend je suis
d'accord avec gérald darmanin pour une
fois
[Musique]
mandaloriennes ce sujet a déjà été
évoqué en début d'année
notamment à l'occasion du vote des
détenus et il y avait alain tourret qui
était rapporteur république en marche si
ma mémoire est bonne à l'assemblée
nationale de ce projet de loi qui est
tiré au rendu un avis défavorable sur ce
sujet puisque il disait que ça allait
jeter un soupçon d'insincérité sur le
vote est tout à fait de cet avis je suis
d'accord avec un parent gérald darmanin
lorsqu'il part du caractère solitaire et
personnels du vote c'est quelque chose
vous savez c'est pas en cassant
thermomètre qu'on fait baisser la fièvre
ben c'est pas en trafiquant les
modalités de l'élection qu'on va ramener
les gens vers vers le vers l'isoloir
encore une fois je pense que la
reconnaissance du vote blanc comme
l'expression d'un suffrage à part
entière avec les conséquences que cela
implique je pense que c'est le tuner
c'est une mesure nécessaire je pense
qu'ensuite habituer les gens à revenir
devant les urnes régulièrement pour des
sujets de société importants ce qui est
l'esprit de la 5ème faut pas oublier que
dans la vème république
le président a à pouvoir qui est
démesuré par rapport à d'autres pays
notamment à par rapport aux états unis
mais que ce pouvoir est censé être
contrebalancé par l'expression du vote
populaire qui est qui s'exprime par le
référendum or depuis général de gaulle
on recourt très rarement à cette
possibilité et en plus de ça à chaque
fois qu'on a encouru on a pris une
décision qui était systématiquement
opposée de celle qui avait été exprimée
par
effectivement c'est une des raisons
aussi exprimé par les électeurs le fait
que finalement leur vote ne changera pas
beaucoup leurs leur quotidien vincent
chauvet
c'est terrible pour la démocratie
absolument ainsi chauffer votre réaction
sur le vote à distance faut-il faut-il
le créole a alors
nouveau modem on a proposé la
proportionnelle et puis le vote à
distance et le vote par anticipation
sur ce point effectivement
on n'a pas encore été suivie j'espère
que ce sera dans le deuxième quinquennat
d'emmanuel macro mais que pour l'instant
ses modalités n'ont pas vraiment évolué
elles existent pour les français de
l'étranger mais nous on pense et on est
même certain que permettent un vote par
anticipation comme ça se fait dans
beaucoup de démocraties un vote par
correspondance par courrier
aussi peut-être plutôt que d'y imposer
le dimanche tous les ans ou alors c'est
ça le vote par anticipation c'est à dire
que vous pourriez aller dans votre
mairie avec une boîte scellée et est
votée pendant trois quatre jours avant
le jour même parce que bien souvent le
dimanche peut y avoir des mariages des
enterrements des gens qui travaillent le
dimanche d impossibilité de se déplacer
des gens qui disent et qu'ils ont des
obligations aussi de garde d'enfants ou
autres ou qui ne sont pas aussi à
l'endroit où ils peuvent se déplacer
simplifier les procurations aujourd'hui
on a eu deux procurations sap a été un
tripatouillage ça n'a pas changé la face
du monde mais ça a permis à des gens
pour les élections les dernières
élections municipales et régionales et
départementales de de faire entendre
leur voix de manière plus simple donc
deux procurations par personne mais
dématérialisée des choses qu'ils soient
très simple très facile aujourd'hui il
faut encore aller dans un commissariat
ou une gendarmerie pour pour le faire ça
c'est des choses qui peuvent aussi
favoriser la participation
évidemment la consultation les
référendums locaux ccl ou nationaux
d'ailleurs les restes d'hommes locaux
sont très peu utilisées très peu utilisé
on pourrait les utiliser davantage une
réflexion aussi quand on demande aux
gens de voter toutes les 5 minutes en
france on vote tous les ans le
calendrier électoral c'est qu'on
implosion tous les ans en attendant cela
aussi à décourager et à favoriser les
lecteurs fidèles et les lecteurs
réguliers donc on pourrait aussi avoir
une réflexion soit calendrier pour
peut-être regroupés comme on l'a fait
sur les départementales régionales et ça
s'est bien passé et bien municipales
européennes ou présidentielle esthétique
ça fait aussi être être des choses comme
ça pour éviter aux gens de se déplacer
toutes les cinq minutes curieusement de
ses 7 centres de découragement et puis
et puis de simplifier des consultations
ou des votations
effectivement sur des sujets locaux ou
régionaux s'est permis par la loi par la
constitution pourtant c'est assez peu
utilisées oui il nous reste peu de temps
on va regarder ce qu'on dit et eric
zemmour on en parlait tout à l'heure on
n'est pas allé jusqu'au bout de la
logique pour lui l'abstention et du jeu
site aux politiques de droite et de
gauche qui se sont ressemblés regarder
l'abstention est due aux politiques de
droite et de gauche qui se sont
rassemblés et le point d'orgue de cette
ressemblance et emmanuel macron les
français ont le droit de voter ils
votent pour n'importe quoi car de toute
façon la politique sera la même après
est-ce qu'il a raison eric zemmour est
ce que les français ne s'y retrouvent
pas dans l'offre politique finalement je
vous pose la question jean marc flipo et
zemmour est un commentateur de la vie
donc il observe il observe qu'en tout un
chacun à ce que c'est ce que je vous
disais c'est ce que je vous disais tout
à l'heure le ce qui est important pour
rappaport ramener les électeurs dans
l'isoloir c'est que son vote compte que
sa voix soit soit respecté que lorsque
l'on fait une fois l'an soit de droite
ou de gauche ont la tienne et mettre en
application son programme or faut bien
le vrai problème c'est quoi c'est que
les personnalités politiques qui se sont
fait élire depuis des années aujourd'hui
en mi temps en mise en oeuvre d'une
politique était quasiment à l' inverse
de ce qu'ils avaient promis aux français
le problème est là et comment voulez
vous que les gens ensuite est confiée
confiance dans leur dans leur classe
politique est allé voter
systématiquement le ce par quoi ils ont
voté dès pas mises en oeuvre et qu'au
contraire celle inverse qui est mise en
avant là c'est ça c'est un problème de
sincérité après on peut commenter eric
zemmour est un journaliste de talent
très bien mais la responsabilité du
politique c'est de respecter ses
engagements
les engagements qu'il a pris les habits
du peuple vincent chauvet une réaction
également a à ce propos d'eric zemmour
réécoutez on voit que la participation
est plus élevée au niveau local moi j'ai
été élu maire avec une forte
participation malgré le vide et à fort
pourcentage bon donc le le le il ya
aussi la l'échelon de confiance et
aujourd'hui la démocratie les plus
fortes au niveau des ddd merck peut-être
la confiance au niveau au niveau
national bon nous on pense effectivement
que si on veut une offre et un vote qui
soit utile il faut aussi de la
proportionnelle notamment législatives
pour que ceux qui veulent voter est mort
et d'avoir d'aider tout député d'extrême
droite et bien et des députés avec
moyens et ceux qui veulent avoir
d'autres offres politiques soient aussi
représenté ça qui amène aussi les
électeurs vers les urnes que chaque voix
compte et pas seulement les voies
majoritaire oui moins de la moitié des
français pensent que voter est un devoir
jean marc flipo une reste quelques
secondes pour réfléchir à ce constat
mais si vous voulez on ne voit qu'elle
vote obligatoire tout à l'heure très
bien mais c'est encore une fois nous
vote obligatoire ne peut être mis en
vigueur que si vous reste possible vote
blanc un client contre là c'est la
première chose ensuite sur la sur la
proportionnelle il faut effectivement
maintenant un style et une part de
proportionnelle dans l'élection
législative c'est ce que va nicolas
dupont aignan propose depuis maintenant
plus de cinq ans il faut quand même
avoir une stabilité démocratique au
parlement donc il faut garder le scrutin
uninominal majoritaire
principalement défaut il ya un certain
nombre de députés effectivement qu'ils
soient élus à la proportionnelle de
manière à ce que toutes les tendances
politiques soient représentés parce que
si vous avez 12 où je crois qu'il avait
19 candidats la dernière fois il faut
que chacun ses candidats effectivement
eu voix au chapitre que puisse être
entendue au sein de l'hémicycle où seul
où s'élaborent les lois le mot de la fin
pour vous vincent chauvet à ce le fait
qu' un saint français sur deux seulement
pensent que voter est un devoir
oui et près d'un jeune sur deux est
également de moins de 30 ans n'est pas
inscrit dans la commune où il réside
donc il ya encore du travail à faire
pour que ceux qui veulent voter puissent
voter et puis il ya aussi le travail de
l'école on est on pourra changer les
lois autant qu'on veut il faut que cette
tendance est que les parents l'école
l'entourage favorise la participation
c'est un travail de tous les jours et
nous élus locaux on est tous les jours
sur le terrain pour montrer que voter
est un devoir et que voter peut servir à
quelque chose merci beaucoup à tous les
deux merci pour ce débat sur
l'abstention
dont on reparlera évidemment avant cette
présidentielle c'est la fin de set